Arena almost flashbacks from last year
this matchup between yourself and a bear
game you start off with white pieces you
get an early Advantage out of the
opening what surprised you
at the beginning yeah well I mean
everything surprised me I certainly
didn't know what um what was the
evaluation of the position
um you know her choice of Bishop G4
Queens Gambit accepted was not something
that came to my mind and
um you know it's funny because I I tried
this line myself maybe a few times in my
life and most recently against hampi
Canario a few years ago and so I I know
that if white doesn't play very
aggressively like black can count on
equality in this line so I just came up
with this move Queen B3
um you know not because I knew anything
here like how this would go but just I
mean I knew it should be like a testing
move
um but I thought she had a lot of
compensation for the pond and it does
seem like Bishop takes F3 first and
perhaps this is what she messed up about
her position Bishop takes F3 and then
Knight to D7 is the main line yeah well
you know there's if you don't have any
computer analysis it's very hard to wade
like through this position like I had no
idea what was going on for probably like
15 moves do you feel she still knew what
she's doing at this point I felt like
maybe Queen B3 surprised her a bit you
know I think she knew this Knight D7
idea but like you know her real thinking
was after Queen B7 like I was actually
thinking like if she goes rugby eight
instead um can I just take the second
Pawn I was gonna take it you know I was
like well I don't know why it's losing
so you know I was probably gonna take it
and there were so many times in this
game where I could have taken a pawn and
it was like some difficult decisions in
that way and I think that was one of the
moments after c592 and now Rook to B8
you could have still things was what I
didn't like here because Queen C8 and
okay interesting so I can escape the
Apple Queen A6 that seemed yeah you know
what I think that move I didn't really
and if she goes to da then you have
Queen C6 later on and if she goes to C7
then she doesn't have a way to attack
your queen yeah I mean you know
um I was trying to figure out her idea
and giving up that pawn and so I came up
with this queen seed and I kind of
believed and I was like oh she has ideas
of like you know CD and then like room
B6 room B4 when the bishop I mean like
so yeah I trusted her in a way I mean I
mean I calculated it but you know
I do believe uh our playoff match
between Ray Robinson and Sam Shanklin
has become
let's get back to it I really not yeah
we'll they have a few more minutes
10 minutes we're going to have
fun with your game no yeah tell us so I
mean basically I just felt like she had
a lot of compensation for a long time
even here like I was wondering should I
take the pawn why didn't I take it here
it was
um this probably would have been the
worst place to take it so you made the
right decision intuitively you know I
went Bishop E2 and it's funny I went to
E2 because I was still thinking of
taking with a knight on D4 and I didn't
want my Bishop to be hit with Knight C5
yeah but when she took on D4 then I was
like you know I thought she still had a
lot of compensation after Knight D4 and
so I went for this Ed position yeah so
this plan with Bishop G6 and Bishop C2
was definitely wrong like I could feel
that because I actually realized because
my Bishop's on E2 she might have this
idea I'm just like but it's actually not
that good like I get to Castle she
spends a couple of moves with his bishop
and she doesn't Castle herself yeah
she's not castled and basically she's
not winning my queen so at this point I
knew I was doing really well
um and the only thing is that
technically speaking this was still
pretty tricky this was a task yeah yeah
I mean winning with those doubled pawns
and I'll just tell you like Knight D3
with Elsa I'll show you something kind
of interesting wait wait oh can I shoot
a trap go back a couple of moves yeah
instead of Queen B7
for example if she goes Queen D6 here
because the threat was you know Rook
takes before yeah I have Knight takes F7
I really did want to do this idea yeah
that's a nice one yeah it would have
been quite nice because I pick up
everything you know on this whole sixth
Rank and the before night before 97 as
well so you don't get a rook at two
pieces but look at one piece and this is
completely losing yeah but she played
Queen B7 she must have seen that and but
this gave me this chance to play Knight
D3 I mean
um to transition with this trade of nice
to finally win the A6 pawn and perhaps
this was her last moment to try to save
the game with the move Rook 2 B8 she has
to focus on not the people
yeah that makes sense definitely I mean
okay we keep going I'll show you the
other move that I thought was
interesting yep
um so here yeah big decision so
basically the idea of Rook D1 you know
was to provoke this E5 move right like I
figured like actually the whole point
was to give my Bishop on A6 like a
better life you know and so I had to get
her to play E5 yes and you know that
Bishop won me the game yes and it's
incredible like you know how you tell
students like focus on your pieces you
know take care of your pieces so they
can help you and I took care of that
bishop and he won the game for me
the bishop didn't win the game the
bishop and the double Pawns in fact the
Double B pawns right yeah yeah and after
that you clinically defended everything
no checks on everyone I didn't feel
clinical to me I mean it was it was
scary with those seconds on the clock
and when and you know when I had to
allow her Knight F3 I mean you know
intuitively you really don't want to do
that but you have to yeah you have to
continue pushing your opponent that's
exactly what you did in the right
configuration
she never was able to get in time to
your king right because this race
between you promoting the pawn and her
getting to your king she never got there
and you won after two Queens on the
board that's a nice nice finish check or
discover a check yeah Irina tomorrow
with the black pieces obviously she will
be coming to the game with aggressive
intentions yeah it's a good thing I'm
aggressive too there we go it's going to
be definitely a fiery matchup guys any
questions for everybody uh
congratulations Irina very very
impressive 3-0 good luck uh tomorrow for
your match thank you Yasser absolutely
uh jumping to our playoff